responding to one tweet from Daily
Sunshine Mike's uh Daily Sunshine says
can someone explain how this works why
doesn't more crime result in people
voting out these those responsible for
safety how do these people stay in power
and democracy I see that it works but I
don't understand from a logical
standpoint how it works
Mike cernovich says Democrats do not
have Noble DNA it's the real divide
right-wing people want freedom and
dignity which is why when we have
political power we don't use it
utterfali the left will live as bug men
stacked on each other pooping everywhere
needle needles in their arms
and he's right
so the the the issue is and I think a
really good example is the the RNC chair
after losing and losing and losing and
just being so absurdly bad at running
the show they just re-elect the same
people
over and over again it's it's the
definition of insanity
so I suppose the issue is it's twofold
what Mike is saying is that Republicans
don't use the power
nothing you're gonna lose that's it
and the bug men are going to win I feel
like young conservatives that I talk to
nowadays are more in line with values
that the freedom caucus is talking about
and I think that you're going to see
them become more and more isolated from
the Republican leadership if they
continue on the path they're on right if
the leadership of the party continues to
say no this is the way we've always done
it and we're going to continue to do it
this way they will lose they will see
youth voters pull away from them and I
think as we know if you can't capture
young voters that you don't really have
a future I think in some ways time is
ticking on the Old Guard in the
Republican Party the same way it's
ticking for the Old Guard and the
Democratic party I mean they are
drifting in all kinds of crazy
directions that they cannot keep up with
I
I think DeSantis is a perfect example
I'm I'm really really off uh uh the
DeSantis train I mean I was I was I was
a big understand this a year ago and
following that's the press conference he
gave just seeing how he's been handling
everything's going on the Press I am
moving further and further away from him
because more and more he represents to
me what the what the failures of the
Republican Party are
he should have got up in front when he
was talking about you know digital
currency Central Bank digital currencies
and he's doing a lot of good things by
being up to date with the problems we're
facing with the culture war with
economic issues I respect that that's a
good thing
and when given the opportunity to be a
leader he said no because he was scared
I think Ron DeSantis was scared he was
scared to say f you to the anti-trump
group for whatever reason if he thinks
he is going to win
any voter from Trump by being weaker
than Trump he is completely wrong and
I'm just I'm looking at what Mike
cernovich said and he made a great point
that Republicans or he said the right
want freedom but anyway they won't use
power he's completely right
just a bunch of cowards and I I I it's
just every step of the way
the the Democrats let's talk about ilhan
Omar and and Marjorie Taylor green
Marjorie Taylor green gets booted off
our committees because a couple of years
before she's elected she posts some
rambling incoherent thing about space
lasers funded by a Rothschild's Bank the
media then spins that into anti-Semitism
and then she's booted from her
committees because Republicans are
cowards not all of them Freedom caucus
you guys are pretty good but then you
get ilhan Omar who makes these repeated
statements in office and then they're
like well you know but let's not uh go
be too hasty there let's just condemn
all bigotry and that's what ends up
happening because the Democrats antifa
these these leftists they can steamroll
they can fire bomb and the media
protects them and Republicans are like
well you know I would say something but
the New York Times will write a mean hit
piece about me so I'm like oh well
that's why people wanted Trump because
Trump told the media to f off and so
they're like there you go you do that do
more of that that's why I was really
excited for pushing back on Kevin
McCarthy when that whole fight happened
we did they were yeah uh as it relates
to Omar she was removed she was voted
off of her a foreign affairs committee
she was after how many years Eric
swalwell he was removed off of uh Intel
because of his relationship with yum yum
[Laughter]
so yeah yum yum so so he's gone but but
we have made it very clear and and uh
listen I was one of the ones I was one
of the freedom caucus guys that gave one
of the uh the nomination speeches for
Kevin McCarthy because I thought that
the battle the real battle uh in the
Republican party is going to be uh when
this important legislation comes through
like the debt ceiling I mean it's been
pretty easy peasy up to this point but
we got these debt sealing increases and
and and trying to actually pass a budget
and we do spending that's when it's
going to start getting very very
difficult for speaker McCarthy and and I
just believe that that right now every
decision that we make as the majority
Authority in the House of
Representatives has to be in the best
interest of getting the White House back
in 2024 because we're talking about
listen we got a great plan Texas uh we
we all came together the representatives
a good border security plan even if we
could get that out of the house it's
dead in the Senate I mean I don't want
to be the bearer of bad news but we
could come up with all the greatest
ideas in the world here in the next two
years with the Republican majority in
the House of Representatives but going
to the Senate and getting anything done
I I can't tell you so that's why it's
right now it's all about investigations
because we've got to expose these
individuals the crooks for who they are
so we can get the White House back in
2024. but legislatively you're just kind
of running out the clock well there's
nothing Well no I think we owe it to the
American people they gave us the gavel
they're begging for leadership so they
gave us the House of Representatives so
now let's lead let's do everything we
can to pass meaningful conservative
legislation through the house let the
American people know that we actually
really care about leadership and and
doing the right thing for America and
America first but then it's going to go
to the Senate run by the Democrats and
it's dead so I think now it's all about
investigations because we need to expose
this family the most corrupt family and
in my humble opinion never served in the
white house we got to expose them for
who they truly are and all of his
friends in the doj the FBI all of them I
don't be doing investigations just
because you you actually cannot pass any
legislation because in the Senate you
should just go and investigate because
you've got nothing better to do but I
don't think that's going to win
anything in 2024. because the game is
different right now likely voters don't
don't matter the reason why the polling
didn't make sense right the polls in the
midterm showed it was going to be
tremendous for the Republican party and
then it was meh and the reason for it is
because when pollsters contact likely
voters and say how do you plan on voting
the likely voter tells them they make a
poll based on it the likely voter then
said Republicans all the way
then they went and knocked on doors at
nursing homes and apartments and got
random non-voters to vote this changed
everything and that's probably the main
reason it was so skewed this time and
Republicans were caught off guard that's
the game right now you don't need this
is this is what the Republicans the
Republican mindset
is I'm gonna go convince that person to
vote for me and the Democrats mindset is
I'm Gonna Knock on their door and tell
them to sign a piece of paper
and that's why they win
they don't got to convince them of
anything
they can they can use social pressure
and fear
or they can make they can remove all
barriers so you got someone knock on
your door and they say what do you want
I'm in the middle of the game did you
fill out your mail-in vote and vote for
the Democrat no I don't want to do well
if you don't vote it if you don't fill
it out right now I will be back here
tomorrow at the same time and if if you
don't do it I'll come back and then
every day they knock on the door and the
guy's like you again fine I'll fill the
thing here you go man have a nice day
they win
that's that that's all that matters
going into I'm imagining these like
these large
um Urban uh living complexes project
housing and other developments in New
York for instance how easy it is for two
20 year old Democrat activists
campaigning on behalf of Joe Biden or
anybody else to go into one building in
one day knock on a door did you vote no
fill it out sign sign your sign your
name I can take it for you they turn
around without moving a single inch and
knock on a door behind them and get
another vote here's the crazier thing
each of these doors could have two or
three people behind them within the
matter within a matter of an hour they
can have 50 votes in their in their bag
Republicans can't do that because
conservatives live in rural areas you're
gonna go drive door to door our closest
neighbor to us to take you about five
minutes to walk to or get in your car
what's Republican oh sorry I haven't
done the research on universal ballot
how many states just mail you a ballot I
don't think it's that many I think there
are some it's the important one so well
it is the important one I understand
that and I haven't looked at the swing
States but I think again it goes back to
the the covet with the emergency
declaration it allowed Governors
Secretary of States and and even County
clerks to start forming their own
opinion uh what the emergency
declaration really meant and how they
could keep their people safe uh social
distancing six feet let's just mail
people a ballot you have to request a
ballot by mail so if if somebody if
you're not gone they're doing
everybody's got a mallet a ballot in
their in their uh I didn't I I
understand but what now in a nursing
home I could understand that because if
you're over 65 it's almost automatic if
you've ever requested one you're going
to get another one is that you shouldn't
have to go and reapply every time but
the the fact of the matter is is that is
that's where I believe Tim I believe
that that that there was the fraud
because a lot of these these ballots uh
there's documentation out there that
said I never voted uh but yeah I know
you did vote no I never I never but how
many stories are you talking about I'm
not I'm just saying where there's one
there's two there's three the point is
that the process the process that we
have to him we have to get control of
because it's not fair it's been abused
you could say whether Democrats are
better at it well maybe they truly are
but there's still many many Americans
and many of them on January 6 that came
up to to protest this thing many of us
are concerned about the way this country
runs elections and and we have to do
something about it because we lose the
Integrity of our elections and I agree
with that but if you believe that the
Democrats one in that that way you will
lose again in 2024. thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time